[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es in der muttertags torte
den muttertag ist bereits nächste woche
also überlegt euch gerne schon mal was
ihr backen möchte ich werde heute alle
kräfte zu bereiten das heißt es wird
eine torte die aus einzelnen kleinen
krebs besteht mit erdbeeren gefüllt denn
ich finde für mich ist ein muttertags
torte immer eine torte mit erdbeer ihr
könnt ihr gerne schreiben ob das für
euch auch so ist der muttertag ist halt
immer zur erdbeerzeit und ihr könnt auch
gerne auf einem kanal vorbeischauen und
in meinem blog in meiner app da gibt es
einfach schon ganz viele muttertags
rezepte schaut gerne mal nach denn ich
glaube die muttertags torten sind immer
die zur erdbeerzeit die immer so am
besten ankommen also heute eine crêpe
torte das bedeutet der ofen bleibt aus
dass auch eine gute torte für alle die
vielleicht keinen backofen haben
studenten küche oder einfach auch sagen
ich will mal was anderes machen jetzt
werde ich erstmal den crap teig
herstellen das ist so ein standard crap
teig rezept plus erdbeeren und weil ich
einfach da schon den erdbeergeschmack
mit rein nehmen möchte habe ich mir
überlegt nämlich gefriergetrocknete
erdbeeren ihr könnt es auch weglassen
ihr könnt auch frische erdbeeren mit
wasser und milch einfach ein bisschen
pürieren arbeit und habt ihr nicht so
dem intensiven geschmack ihr könnt aber
auch weglassen und sagen ich nehme
einfach nur die erdbahn in erfüllung das
passt auch ganz gut dass einfach nur so
von mir so ein top also für den crap
teig verwende ich zehn gramm
gefriergetrocknete erdbeeren einen
esslöffel zucker 500 gramm mehl da
können dann zum beispiel dinkelmehl
verwenden sechs eier jeweils 500 gramm
mineralwasser und milch einen halben
teelöffel salz etwas vanille extrakt 100
gramm flüssige butter und dann könnt ihr
gerne noch lebensmittelfarben nehmen in
rosa und rot zum beispiel
ich werde es zuerst einmal diese
gefriergetrockneten erdbeeren die
bekommt ihr übrigens auch in
supermärkten in drogeriemärkten oft auch
in der baby abteilung da gibt's nämlich
diese erdbeer chips einfach für kinder
und das sind eben gefriergetrocknete
oder bestellen sie online da sind sie
oft einfach auch ein bisschen in
größeren verpackungen und auch ein
bisschen günstiger falls sie oft damit
backen wollte
jetzt hier die erdbeeren mit dem zucker
erst einmal fein mahlen
schön pulverisieren
dann schalte ich jetzt immer auf ein
etwas kleinerer stufe
ihr könnt jetzt den crap teig entweder
mit einem kochlöffel zubereiten
schneebesen oder einfach im mixer ich
gebe es erstmal die flüssigen zutaten
hier rein
so verhindert ihr auch direkt die
klümpchen bildung
aber ansonsten schaut auch gerne mal
abstand block vorbei oder in meinen
videos denn ich habe auch mal gezeigt
wie man crap teig richtig rührt ich
nehme ich immer schön mail von außen
nach innen auch mit dem kochlöffel ganz
einfach möglich
wasser noch rein
ich jetzt kurz
und dann kommen jetzt hier einfach alle
zutaten rein nacheinander
ich glaube ich mache zum frühstück oft
die halbe menge
traue ich mich gesetzt
haben willst du dich das jetzt traue
ich nehme jetzt das mach ich
packe jetzt alles die eier macht dort so
aber ihr könnt auch gerne einfach das
mehl mit den flüssigkeiten vermischen
und den rest an in einer großen schüssel
verrühren ist
eine große schüssel
aber bevor ich jetzt hier die komplett
sauerei macht natürlich nehme ich lieber
eine große schüssel
dann auf jeden fall auch flüssige butter
vanille extrakt und salz und schön
verrühren
und wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr jetzt das
ganze hier mit lebensmittelfarben
einfärben am besten durch einfach so ein
bisschen was raus können sehr gut
verrühren und dann in die große menge
einmischen
[Musik]
ich habe ich hier ein schönes zartes
rosa
und wenn ihr die farbe immer erst in
einem separaten schälchen anrührt und
dann zum großen tag dazu gibt könnt ihr
zum einen bestimmen wie farb- intensives
wird und zum anderen verteilt sich die
farbe einfach besser deswegen gebe ich
nicht die farbe hier direkt mit rein
okay das ist jetzt erst mal fertig ich
fange an mit einem zarten rosa behalte
lebensmittelfarbe aber noch da denn ich
mache sondern ombre effekt rein das
heißt ich werde die pfannkuchen erst mal
hell packen und dann ein paar dunkle und
später hat sie schon ein farbverlauf ich
hier kurz alles wegräumen kurz sauber
machen das kann geschwind gestellt
die schwellen quellen
schnellen sollten deshalb gewählt und
dann hole ich eine pfanne zum ausbacken
den mixer magische bringen so sauber ich
mach wasser ein bisschen spüli es sich
gegen den geruch
und dann einfach schön laufen lassen ich
habe hier sogar eine reinigungsfunktion
muss man sagen das ist hier die unterste
und dann wird schön sauber
perfekt dann ist uns nämlich bei den mix
mehr so schön sauber und oben kommt man
im schwarm ganz gut hin
ich werde dir ne kleine beschichtete
pfanne nehmen und
ich könnte eigentlich ohne fett die
crêpes ausbacken
und mach jetzt schöne kleine krebs damit
die torte eben nicht so groß sondern
eher klein aber dafür hoch wird und ich
werde mal schauen ich glaube ich drittel
den teig das heißt ein drittel wird hell
ein drittel wird ein bisschen dunkler
unten drittel noch mal dunkler und dann
sagte tepper frau beiden seiten schön
aus
ich habe sogar eine crêpe stufe auf dem
härtsfeld meckereien
stufen vier und dann sagte er mir
nämlich ich kann hier nämlich auf den
perfekt frei es ist gehen und dann kann
ich hier stufe 4 machen und dann
verbrennen die crêpes nämlich nicht
sondern haben immer die perfekte farbe
und sind immer gleichmäßig gar
gut dass für das krawall fällt also
falls ihr auch die herdplatte habt von
bosch dann könnt ihr wirklich die
perfekt frei funktion benutzen die ist
nämlich echt gut dann erhitzt sich die
pfanne gibt ein gleichen signal und der
herd optimiert dann quasi von alleine
immer die temperatur und gleicht sie an
als es dann nicht so dass es mal zu kalt
oder zu warm ist sondern die temperatur
ist immer gleich gleichbleibend
das war das signal
und jetzt weiß ich die pfanne ist heiß
genug
also los geht's
da jetzt einfach eine kleine schöpfkelle
das reicht auf jeden fall
und ich wende die crêpes immer dann wenn
die oberfläche eben schön auch angedickt
ist bzw gar ist und dann könnte das hier
einmal am rand lösen
und dann schön wenden und die crêpes
auspacken
und wenn ihr zwei gleich grosse parade
und habt könnt ihr gleich beide
gleichzeitig auspacken da geht es
bisschen schneller
jetzt hab ich noch ned gemacht
jetzt habe ich hier schon in stapel
crêpes und jetzt kommt die zweite farbe
dran und nach dieser farbe werde ich
noch mal verdoppeln
das gute bei der perfekte funktion ist
selbst wenn die pfanne jetzt lesern das
erhitzt mit deswegen habe ich jetzt hier
gratis die pfanne auf dem herd und die
temperatur hält sich ganz gut
[Musik]
meine krebs sind jetzt alle gebacken und
ich lasse jetzt schön auskühlen
währenddessen kann ich schon mal die
creme zubereiten könnte crêpes auch
gerne abdecken nach dem abkühlen damit
sie einfach nicht austrocknen aber lasst
sie weg sagt erstmal abkühlen jetzt wird
nemours cup ohne sahne creme zubereitet
ihr könnt eine frisch käse sahne creme
zubereitet alles was euch schmeckt oder
quark sahne ist auch gut jedenfalls
dachte ich mascarpone seine erdbeeren
das wird die perfekte kombi für die
muttertags torte
wird doch nicht nur darauf aus torte
füllen denn ich hatte noch was anderes
vor heute geht es aber weiter mit der
torte ihr könnt wie gesagt die crêpes
auskühlen lassen aber müsste luftdicht
verpacken so habe ich das auch gemacht
und jetzt kommt die creme an die reihe
für die creme verwende ich 500 gramm
mascarpone 250 gramm quark 100 gramm
puderzucker etwas vanille extrakt
limetten abrieb und limettensaft 400
gramm sahne und salat gebt ihr zuerst
die mascarpone in der rührschüssel
den quark dazu
gut abzocken und
dann etwas vanille extrakt limetten
abrieb und limettensaft
[Musik]
und sobald sich alles verbunden hat
könnt ihr die sache langsam dazu gießen
und die creme mit seiner band stadt
schlagen
dann stelle ich die creme kurz in den
kühlschrank hole erdbeeren und auch noch
einen tortenring zum ausstechen der
böden
sehen wir euch die krebs und am besten
einen tortenring denen bisschen kleiner
einstellen damit er die krebs aus
frechen könnt und eben diesen flotten
ich habt ihr könnt es auch so lassen
dann habt ihr aber eben keine
gleichmäßige torte sondern eher können
also der naked trotzdem haben das auch
gut aber das möchte ich heute nicht
ich glaub ich schneid
in das dort ausstechen könnte dann ist
das halt ausschneiden geht auch
[Musik]
aus den resten könnt ihr zum beispiel
ein glas des erzeugern oder sie einfach
so verlassen ich hatte kurz überlegt sie
zu karamellisieren mit dem die torte zu
geben aber das wird alles zu aufwändig
muss ich sagen für die torte jetzt habe
ich hier noch erdbeeren ganz schöne
frische bereits vom grün entfernt und
die schneidet ihr sinn scheiben entweder
mit einem messer oder einfach nur auf
das können kinder ganz schön machen das
finde ich so toll weil die sich da eben
nicht in die finger schneiden und dann
legt ihr die nämlich einfach hierhin
und am ende ein mal hier rein und dann
habt ihr eben perfekte etwa schneiden
alles schön gleichmäßig
[Musik]
damit die torte jetzt gefüllt ich nehme
sie einen torten drehteller und hab da
immer gerne eine anti rutsch motte drauf
dann rutscht er trocken retter nicht
dann nehmt ihr den ersten
pfannkuchen trap der kommt hier in die
mitte und ich stapel das jetzt von
dunkel noch hell und jetzt einfach immer
so ein bisschen creme darauf dass du
viel
wirklich ein bisschen dann erdbeeren
darüber verteilen und die torte schön
stapeln und wenn ihr nicht so ganz geübt
seit importen gerade stapeln könnt ihr
auch jetzt einen tortenring hier
hinlegen und dann nehmt ihr einfach eine
top ring palette dann kann man das auch
schön streichen und dann wird sie eben
nicht schief so schön gerade aber damit
ihr das jetzt besser sieht mache ich das
jetzt ohne tortenring
die schöne schicht hatte
und immer schön flach arbeiten
die erste farbe ist schon fertig jetzt
bin ich hier bei farbe 2
ist schon ein bisschen aufwendig aber
ich finde für die mauer macht man halt
was besonderes oder für eine freundin
oder für einen ehepartner oder seinen
freund dafür sich zum geburtstag
als ich habe man schlechte und eine gute
nachricht die gute nachricht ist die
torte sieht schonmal gut auf die
schlechte nachricht ist die creme gleich
leer die reichen nicht mehr für alles
aber die gute nachricht ist dass mein
kühlregal mein kühlschrank so fröhlich
wie disco regal bei lidl das heißt ich
mache einfach nochmal die gleiche
funktion creme denn ich brauche auch was
für die dekoration und für obendrauf
falls eure torte nicht so hoch werden
soll dann halbiert einfach das würde ich
jetzt einfach mal waren denn die jetzt
schon mega hoch
ich stelle die torte kurz kalt rühren
nochmal kremann und dann völlig so weit
aber uns bisschen verschätzt mit der
menge ich habe jetzt gedacht dass ich
sie doch so hoch mache
achso so gegen ende muss man schon
aufpassen dass es keine kuppel torte
wird gerne aber ich habe da ein tipp für
euch ich nehme immer gern seine palette
und dann streiche ich hier in die mitte
und die creme gleich das dann wieder gut
aus die app macht es natürlich nicht
einfacher aber das wird schon das wird
und wie gesagt am besten durch ein
tortenring ich lege auch gleich einen
aber ich möchte dass ihr seht wie die
torte hoch wird wie sie sich fühlt und
stapelt
wird und dann ist es doch schön
ausgiebig aber ich glaube die hälfte des
rezept wird auch reichen dann hat man
vielleicht einfach noch ein paar
pfannkuchen übrig zum frühstücken und
selbst belegen aber ich habe anfangs
echt gedacht die trotte widmet hoch
genug und jetzt sprengt den rahmen das
ist schon schön ich mich schön ich mag
das
nicht
so großzügig werde mit der creme denn
ich brauche noch kriegen wir die deko
außen
deswegen sehr vorsichtig
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich präsentiere euch die schiefe nase
vorn war kaiser deswegen lege ich dir
keine torten rand rollier drumherum denn
ansonsten wird die torte richtig schief
und
ein hoher tortenring zum stabilisieren
wie gesagt ihr könnt auch direkt im
großen ring führen und dann wird sie
gleich gemacht
dann kann man nämlich auch so ein
bisschen noch nach drücken dann geht die
ganze luft die ihnen das heute ist noch
weg und die glätte zwischen wenig
tut sogar noch ein bisschen mit der
burger presse
in zwei schichten mache ich noch rein
aber
dann ist gut
so wäre es dann praktisch wenn ihr
direkt mit dem tortenring fühlt da kommt
halt auch ganz gut rein
und es ist ein einfacher mann hat dann
etwa den stress dass die täter gerade
schick wird
gerade
und die letzte schicht die mache ich
jetzt so dass keine erdbeeren drin sind
also passt ich habe es noch viel
pfannkuchen bricht das passt ganz gut
und jetzt denke ich die torte ab und
stellen sie für mindestens zwei bis drei
stunden in den kühlschrank damit sie
jetzt erst mal stabilität bekommt und
die creme kommt auch im kühlschrank
und dann sehen wir uns gleich
die torte ist jetzt schon gekühlt hoffe
ich zumindest ich
behaupte es halt immer so arbeit jeweils
schon lange im kühlschrank
partie sieht schon gut aus
ich werde jetzt natürlich
natürlich die creme auf der folie noch
abkratzen
[Musik]
kommt hier
das che mit drauf
und dann nehme ich jetzt einfach mal
direkt creme und streicht erstmal den
rams schönen glas und dann noch die
oberfläche
eigentlich macht wenn man erst die
oberfläche und dann den rand
mit einer palette geht es noch mal ganz
gut
[Musik]
ich lasse meine torte so stellt sie kurz
kalt der rest der creme wandert in den
spritzbeutel und ich haben im cache trip
den ich kurz in der mikrowelle oder im
wasserbad erwärmt werden sie könnten
kate trip auch selber machen aber ihr
könnt auch den unternehmen weil ich
nicht viel brauchen nämlich tatsächlich
heute in oslo war ich brauche nur so ein
paar keine stellen aber die torte darf
so lange im kühlschrank
welche rasch weiß mit decken ohne
aber dann
doch ich glaube man macht es mit mit mit
deckeln
die metall den metall verschluss bitte
entfernen
und dann cache trip in die mikrowelle
wie viel watt
sie hat es dann auch kamera
sprach die
erste wahl
[Gelächter]
weil
weil die krebse weich sind und sich
durch
jesus maria was mache ich dann jetzt
am besten füllt er die torte direkt auf
eurer tortenplatte
gar nicht erst richtig
ja weil der crêpes dass der pakt ist
jutta ihrer klassenstufe bit
bleiben gleich also das ist die
rückseite die vorderseite wie sieht die
aus
ich bin natürlich jetzt auch sofern
zeigt auf der rückseite
es sah schlimm aus
ich hab's gerettet denn der halbe crêpes
boden herunter weg ja am besten
tatsächlich direkt auf der tortenplatte
stapeln
damit gar nicht erst kaputt geht ich
kann mich nimmt gar kein rosa
und jetzt könnte die restliche creme
nehmen und die torte schön dekorieren
ich hatte kurz überlegt nur so ein paar
tupfer und bisschen erdbeeren aber ich
glaube eben auch die talk weitflächig
hab mich doch umentschieden und
dann kommen noch erdbeeren dazwischen
und dann noch so reflex metallic schoko
flex
und dann können wir jetzt noch für die
mama oktober drauf machen
oder auf deutsch danke für alles was ich
sonst macht oder la vie oder alles gute
muss man nehmen
love you find ich auch zuerst
die cake pops an der hand die
techno-party könnt ihr auch immer wieder
verwenden sind holz kriegsopfer und wenn
ihr möchtet könnt ihr sie sogar mit
lebensmittelfarben ansprüchen aber ich
finde gerade diese natürliche holzoptik
einfach so schön wie wir nämlich
gelasert ich finde es richten autos
richtung bisher nach verbranntem holz
und dann packen moment ihr ende juli
fertig ist der muttertag torte ich muss
euch noch kurz einen tipp zeigen und
zwar gibt es aka aka spray also
tortenguss zum sprühen falls ihr nämlich
an geschnittene früchte habt wie
erdbeeren dann bekommen sie einen
schönen glanz wenn ihr damit das drauf
schaut mal und die halten länger weil
sie dann eben nicht mehr oxidieren das
heißt es das gleiche prinzip wie mit
orten goss tortenguss muss man aber auf
kochen und dann drüber streichen oder
darüber gießen und das können da einfach
so drauf springen und dann habt ihr
okay ich hatte wird es angeschnitten von
von mir und jutta koether dem muttertag
ist total irgendwie gedacht zwei master
hat mobilien gerne machen wir das so und
heute machen wir uns ganz anders
kannte
mutter hat angst dass ich mit dem messer
durch die torte kommen ich mich aber
ganz ehrlich sagen ich probier's
potsdam eine tonne schmeißen
wir probieren es erst
wenn es nicht geht
und der typ da trifft es
[Musik]
geht gut aber ich verspreche dir wir
schneiden später noch mit dem
elektrischen bisschen action hier in der
kritik sehr dass geht viele käfer und
fiel einfach verdrückt nicht so
ehrlich
ok ich glaub dir wir machen einmal den
instagram moment mit den schichten und
dann und dann machen wir das noch mit
deinen ich glaube dir fällt um ich sag's
dir fällt um wollte ich brauche mal ich
hab schon hinter mir sitzen
ich habe schulden tilge war sein traum
und
autos sind schon viele pfannkuche
geworden und dann noch mit der färbung
mit dem amberger nicht richtig schön
angeeckt dyballa standorten nicht einmal
probieren
würde studierte nachmachen
[Gelächter]
nein warum
weil das viel arbeit während nach wie
viel rummel und gefunden das ist nichts
für mich sagt bei jeder tag haben wir
relativ teuren und aufwändigen den sack
zum alter die schon längst drei
blechkuchen gebacken 30 kommst du alles
glücklich alle sind satt und juhu
verraten aber es gibt ja viele die gerne
lange in der küche schwere attacken sind
gebacken das danach gern das ist schon
toll die strahlung nicht gar nicht
gut die pfannkuchen mit mascarpone creme
und etwa inhalt
super league
haben wir ja eigentlich gezählt
pfannkuchen das dürfen jetzt die
zuschauer machen
dürfte gerne mal schreiben was ihr
glaubt wie viele schichten in dieser
torte stecken oder ja dann wünsche ich
den alma mater einen wunderschönen
muttertag wie gesagt nächste woche am 8
mai ist muttertag denkt da noch immer
maß und omas und handeln und alle
freunde natürlich aber natürlich kann
man die torte auch zu jedem anderen
anlass zu bereiten lasst euch alle
verwöhnen ja ganz wichtig genießt den
tag macht gut wird zum nächsten mal
lasst euch ein messer aus korea kommen
auf
einmal und nicht zögerte und dann sicher
ich muss aber noch fotos schießen
humor ist super so waren natürlich der
perfekte bei der abfahrt drückt nämlich
nicht sehr gut das nehmen wir jetzt mit
in torten anschnitt
[Gelächter]
[Musik]